THAT'S WHO THEY ARE.
THEY LOVE INVITING.
MY EXCLUSIVE TAKE ON THAT.
ALL OF THAT AND MORE IN OUR
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE START TONIGHT AN
IMPORTANT MONOLOGUE ON THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
HERE IS WHAT I WANT TO EXPLAIN
TO YOU.
HATING PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THERE
DRUG AND THE MEDIA.
BY THE WAY, TO THEM IT'S MORE
ADDICTIVE THAN HEROIN AND CRACK
COCAINE.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
BECAUSE IN THE LIBERAL MEDIA
BUBBLE, A TRUMP TWEET LITERALLY
SENDS THEM INTO ORBIT,
ALKA-SELTZER AND WATER, THEY
THEIR BRAINS, THE DRUG IS THAT
POWERFUL.
THEY CAN'T GET IT ANY OTHER WAY.
TWEETS TO GET AROUND THE MEDIA
AND THEIR TWISTED, DISTORTED
FAKE NEWS COVERAGE.
TIMES WITH HUMOR THEY CAN'T
RECOGNIZE.
THE MEDIA THAN PROBABLY
PROCEEDS, THEY RUSH TO THE
AIRWAVES AND THEY TRY TO OUTDO
EACH OTHER FEIGNING MORE
OUTREACH THAN THE OTHER ONE.
HERE'S THE LATEST EXAMPLE.
WATCH, JUST WATCH HOW THE MEDIA
REACTED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
RECENT TWEETS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
>> 16 TWEETS TODAY TO START THE
NEW YEAR.
SOME OF THEM DEEPLY DISTURBING.
THESE ARE THE MESSAGES FROM A
PERSON WHO IS NOT WELL, FROM A
LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
HAVE BEEN REJECTED FROM THE
SCRIPT OF DR. STRANGELOVE.
WE CAN'T BEGIN TO NORMALIZE
THIS.
THIS IS DANGEROUS, THIS IS
CHILDISH, THIS IS
NONPRESIDENTIAL.
NOT BEFITTING THE LEADER IN THE
FREE WORLD.
>> NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL, NONE
OF THIS COMFORTABLE.
NONE OF THIS FRANKLY STABLE
BEHAVIOR.
>> THIS IS SO FAR OUTSIDE THE
PRINCIPLES AND THE NORMS OF
PRESIDENTIAL BEHAVIOR THAT WE
ARE IN AN OUTER SPACE REALM HERE
ARE IN AN OUTER SPACE REALM HER
HERE.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN
AUTHORITARIAN COUNTRIES.
>> HE NEEDS TO BE MEDICATED AND
HOSPITALIZED AT THIS POINT OR HE
IS GOING TO JUST KILL ALL OF US.
>> HE IS NOT REALLY BEING
CAVALIER WITH A THREAT ABOUT
NUCLEAR WAR.
HE'S BEING CAVALIER IN A WAY
>> PERHAPS NEVER HAVE WE SEEN A
MAN WHOSE PROFOUND SEXUAL AND
MASCULINE INSECURITIES ARE
LITERALLY THREATENING TO
ANNIHILATE THE PLANET.
LET'S SEE, BECAUSE HE WAS
RESPONDING TO A NUCLEAR THREAT
FROM NORTH KOREA?
NOT ONLY ARE THEY ALL A BUNCH OF
SHEEP, YOU NOTICE THEY ALSO
THEY CRAVE THEIR NEXT TRUMP
TWEET.
THEY NEED THEIR FIX AND IF, FOR
SOME REASON, THERE IS NOT A
TWEET WITHIN 24 HOURS, THERE'S
NOT A COMMENT, THERE'S NO FAKE
OUTRAGE, WHILE THEY HAVE TO
LATCH ON TO SOMETHING THAT WILL
SATISFY THEIR CRAVING.
IF THEY JUST RACED BACK TO THEIR
GATEWAY DRUG.
TRUMP, RUSSIA, TRUMP, RUSSIA.
BUT WITH THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
EQUIVALENT TO METHADONE, IT'S
ONLY A MAINTENANCE DRUG THAT
BARELY SEPARATES THEM FROM LIKE
A PADDED ROOM IN SOME ASYLUM
SOMEWHERE.
AND FOR OVER A YEAR YOU HAVE
BEEN SUBJECTED TO RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION, ILLUSION.
THE MEDIA DESPERATELY REPEATING
THOSE WORDS DAILY HOPING THAT
SOMEHOW IF THEY SAY IT ENOUGH
IT'S GOING TO COME TRUE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, IT'S NOT
TRUE.
THERE IS TO DATE ZERO EVIDENCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA, NONE.
WHATSOEVER.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
SO THE MEDIA NOW NEEDED A NEW
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THEY CAN
PASS OFF AS NEWS TO GET
THEMSELVES, WELL, BACK ON THEIR
DRUG, GET HOOKED AGAIN.
IN ONE SENSE IT'S SAD, BECAUSE
THESE PEOPLE REALLY NEED HELP.
THEY HAVE NO, LET'S SAY, THEY
DON'T WANT TO ADHERE TO TRUTH
WATCH THE NEWS DO THEY EVER TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING DONALD TRUMP THAT
BECAUSE THEY NEVER THOUGHT HE'D
WIN BACK DO THEY EVER TALK ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, SOLUTIONS
FOR HEALTH CARE, GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF POVERTY, OFF OF FOOD
STAMPS, BACK TO WORK?
I NEVER HEAR IT.
IF THE MEDIA REALLY CARED ABOUT
ANYTHING OF REAL IMPORTANCE,
THEN GUESS WHAT, THEY WOULD HAVE
TO ALTER THEIR CONSTRUCTIVE
WORSHIP SITES OF OBAMA DURING
HIS FAILED PRESIDENCY.
BY THE WAY, IN THOSE YEARS THEY
WOULD HAVE SEEN THE MILLIONS OF
MORE AMERICANS IN POVERTY AND ON
FOOD STAMPS, THEY WOULD HAVE
STOOD UP FOR YOU, BUT LIKING
OBAMA WAS MORE IMPORTANT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWEETS ABOUT
NORTH KOREA, LET'S GET INTO THIS
NORTH KOREA, LET'S GET INTO THI
THIS.
IS SO DANGEROUS THAT YOU SEE
THEM UNLEASHED LIKE THEY DID IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS?
LET'S SEE, HE STOOD UP TO A TWO
BIT MURDERING DICTATOR AND HE
CALLED HIM LITTLE ROCKET MAN AND
HE SAID THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS NOT GOING TO BE INTIMIDATED
BY HIS LITTLE RED BUTTON ON HIS
PERSONALLY SUPPORT ARE THE
POLICIES OF APPEASEMENT.
SO WE HAVE TO ASK, IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
COULD DO TO MAKE THE MEDIA EVER
HAPPY IN THE SITUATION WITH
KIM JONG UN?
THE PRESS PROBABLY WANTS
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- MAYBE THEY
WOULD BE HAPPY IF HE GOT DOWN ON
HIS KNEES AND KISSED
KIM JONG UN'S RING ON HIS LITTLE
HAND.
THEN THEY WOULD BE CALLING FOR
HIM TO GET THE NOBEL PRIZE.
OR MAYBE THE MEDIA WOULD BE
HAPPY IF TRUMP GAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FUEL SUBSIDIES TO
NORTH KOREA LIKE BILL CLINTON
DID.
OR MAYBE TRUMP SHOULD SUCK UP
GROVELED TO KIM JONG IL, HIS
LIKE THIS.
>> THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND THEN
DISMANTLE ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
SOUTH KOREA AND OUR OTHER ALLIES
WILL BE BETTER PROTECTED.
THE ENTIRE WORLD WILL BE SAFER
AS WE SLOW THE SPREAD OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
SOUTH KOREA WITH SUPPORT IN
TO MAKE UP FOR THE NUCLEAR
ENERGY IT IS LOSING.
AND THEY WILL PAY FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE POWER SYSTEM FOR
NORTH KOREA THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO PRODUCE ELECTRICITY WHILE
MAKING IT MUCH HARDER FOR THEM
TO PRODUCE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE UNITED STATES AND
INTERNATIONAL INSPECTORS WILL
CAREFULLY MONITOR NORTH KOREA TO
ONLY AS IT DOES SO WILL
NORTH KOREA FULLY JOIN THE
COMMUNITY OF NATIONS.
>> Sean: COULD BILL CLINTON
HAVE BEEN MORE WRONG?
THEY WOULD BE ECSTATIC, REALLY,
REALLY HAPPY IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUCKED UP TO THE IRANIAN
MULLAHS.
IT MAY BE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
SENT THEM ANOTHER $150 BILLION
LIKE OBAMA DID AND BEGGED ON HIS
HANDS AND KNEES, PRETTY, PRETTY,
PRETTY PLEASE.
HERE'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, JUST
PLEASE STOP SAYING YOU ARE GOING
TO WIPE US OFF THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
PLEASE STOP SAYING YOU WILL
DESTROY ISRAEL.
PLEASE STOP BURNING OUR FLAGS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT IN THE
PRESS, THAT'S PATHETIC.
THEY ARE LAZY AND THEY ARE
OTHER IN THEIR LITTLE MEDIA
BUBBLE.
THE SKY IS LITERALLY FALLING
DOWN FOR THESE PEOPLE ALL
MURDERING DICTATOR.
OVER THEMSELVES.
THEY WANT TO ALL OUT TO EACH
OTHER.
IF LIKE THE COMPETITION.
LET'S SEE WHO CAN BE THE MOST
ANTI-TRUMP AND IF ONE LIBERAL
MEDIA PERSONALITIES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DEMENTED,
THEN ANOTHER HAS TO STEP IN AND
SAY NO, HE'S REALLY, REALLY
DEMENTED, AND HE'S REALLY,
REALLY A BIG, BIG, BIG, BIG WIRE
AND IT GOES ON FROM THERE.
IT'S LIKE IN PART -- IT'S LIKE
INITIATION INTO THEIR HATE TRUMP
CLUB AND TO BE A MEMBER YOU JUST
HAVE TO HATE EVERYTHING.
IT'S HAPPENING EVERY SINGLE HOUR
OF EVERY SINGLE DAY ON EVERY
SINGLE NEWS CHANNEL AND IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA NONSTOP.
THAT'S ALL THEY DO.
THAT'S THEIR GO TO.
AND THAT IS WHAT NOW THE MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY HAS BECOME AND
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN TELLING YOU
SINCE 2007 AND 2008, JOURNALISM
IN AMERICA IS DEAD.
IT'S DONE.
IF THE SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS,
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT TRUTH
ANYMORE.
FAX BE DAMNED, EVIDENCE BE
DAMNED, BECAUSE IF THEY DID CARE
ABOUT TRUTH, THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
START DOING THEIR JOB.
IF THEY WOULD BE INVESTIGATING
MASSIVE SCANDALS THAT ARE
STARING THEM RIGHT IN THE FACE.
THEY COULD WIN THE PULITZER
PRIZE OR AS THEY ARE DREAMING
ABOUT.
NONE OF WHAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
TELL YOU IS IMPORTANT TO THE
MEDIA, BUT IT ALL SHOULD BE.
THEY ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
IT'S ABOUT THE SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
IN AMERICA.
IT'S NOW HANGING IN THE BALANCE,
EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE LAW.
THE MEDIA IGNORES THIS, WHY?
AN EXPLOSIVE REPORT, THE HILL'S
JOHN SOLOMON REVEALING THAT
WRITTEN FBI DOCUMENTS SHOW
AGENTS WORKING ON THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION ALL BELIEVE
INTERVIEWED AFTER JAMES COMEY
ALREADY DRAFTED THE EXONERATION
STATEMENT OF HILLARY.
THE FIX WAS IN, IT WAS RAKED.
IT WAS EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE EVEN MORE PROOF, DOES
THE MEDIA EVEN CARE ABOUT IT, OR
ARE THEY SPREADING THEIR
TRUMP-RUPTURE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES?
IS THAT MORE IMPORTANT AFTER A
YEAR OF NO FACTS AND A YEAR OF
CLINTON-LOVING FBI AGENT'S PETER
STRZOK AND HIS FBI GIRLFRIEND
LISA PAGE.
COMPLETELY TRASHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TEXT
MESSAGES.
THEY CALLED HIM A LOATHSOME
HUMAN BEING, AN IDIOT AND STRZOK
OFFICE, WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE CASE DONALD TRUMP WON
VERBIAGE IN THE EXONERATION
NONE OF THIS IS IMPORTANT TO THE
MEDIA?
IT SHOULD BE.
DEMOCRATIC GENEROUS DONORS, THEY
DON'T DONATE TO REPUBLICANS.
50 GRAND TO DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING
HILLARY AND BARACK OBAMA.
AND OF COURSE NONE OF THEM GAVE
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
ONE OF MUELLER'S LEAD
INVESTIGATOR'S WRIGHT ACTUALLY
REPRESENTED CLINTON AND THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION IN 2015.
YOU CAN'T GET A BIGGER CONFLICT
WE HAVE MUELLER'S TOP
PROSECUTOR.
THE EXPERT ANDREW WISEMAN, THE
PROFESSIONAL HE IS.
HE LET THE EXTREMELY
CONTROVERSIAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE CASE AGAINST ARTHUR
ANDERSEN ACCOUNTING AS PART OF
THE ENRON SCANDAL.
HE DESTROYED THE COMPANY, COST
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THEIR JOBS AND WAS OVERTURNED IN
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT IN '059-
EXECUTIVES TO JAIL.
THEIR CONVICTIONS WERE ALSO
OVERTURNED.
THAT CASE BY THE FIFTH U.S.
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
DOES THE MEDIA NOT CARE ABOUT
ANY OF THIS?
IT WAS A BUNCH OF REPUBLICAN
DONORS GIVING DONATIONS TO
TRUMP, INVESTIGATING
EVER?
REALLY?
NEXT, OF COURSE, YOU HAVE THE
DEMOTED DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE ORR,
HIS WIFE NELLIE.
HE MEETS WITH MEMBERS OF
FUSION GPS BEFORE AND AFTER THE
2016 ELECTION AND HIS WIFE,
NELLIE ORR WORKED FOR THE FIRM
PROPAGANDA RUSSIAN-TRUMP DOSSIE.
FINALLY THE FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE AND HIS WIFE JILL GET
700 GRAND FROM A LONG TIME
CLINTON ALLY.
ALL THAT MONEY GIVEN FOR A
FAILED VIRGINIA STATE SENATE
RUN.
THAT IS AN ASTRONOMICAL SUM IN A
SENATE RACE IN VIRGINIA.
THESE ARE ALL INDIVIDUALLY
MASSIVE STORIES.
NOT EVEN MENTIONING URANIUM ONE.
LET'S SEE, BRIBERY, EXTORTION,
MONEY LAUNDERING, KICKBACKS.
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S THUGS WERE IN
COUNTRY?
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH, WE NEED
MORE.
IT'S INSANE.
I DO LOOK AT THE MONEY BEHIND
THAT.
YOU HAVE MOUNTAINS OF EVIDENCE
HERE OF WRONGDOING.
IF THE MEDIA IS NOT TOUCHING ANY
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS INFATUATED.
THEY CANNOT CONTROL THEMSELVES
ANYMORE, AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
HATING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE A SICKNESS.
THEY CAN'T SEE ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT IS THEIR SINGULAR FOCUS.
EVEN, BY THE WAY, THEY WOULD
THE MEDIA IS BETRAYING YOU, THE
WOULD THINK THEY WOULD HAVE SOME
SORT OF ETHICAL COMPASS,
SOMETHING THAT WOULD MOVE THEM
TOWARDS TRUTH.
BUT THEY ARE NOW SO CORRUPTED,
MORALLY BANKRUPT, THEY HATE ANY
AND EVERYBODY THAT DOESN'T DO IT
THEIR WAY.
THE MEDIA TONIGHT, THEY ARE
HYPERVENTILATING AGAIN, FOAMING
AT THE MOUTH.
AT THE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR STEVE
BANNON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDING TO
COMMENTS, BANNON APPARENTLY MADE
HERE'S THE THING, THE MEDIA
LOVES, LOVES STEVE BANNON FOR
THE MOMENT.
THEY LOVE ONE REPUBLICANS ARE
CONSERVATIVES ARE FIGHTING AND
CREATE A CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD.
IN REAL LIFE THEY HATE BANNON
AND THEY HATE TRUMP, BUT RIGHT
NOW THEY WILL BE SUPPORTIVE OF
STEVE BANNON IF THEY THINK HE'S
THEY LOVE INTRIGUE.
ABILITY TO ANALYZE WHO'S UP,
WHO'S DOWN.
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE, THE
MEDIA'S PRIORITIES ARE SO
SCREWED UP.
WHEN ARE THEY EVER ABOUT MAKING
YOUR LIFE BETTER, YOUR KIDS'
LIVES BETTER?
HERE'S ANOTHER THING THAT I'VE
SAID BEFORE.
ANYONE WHO WORKS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, YOU ARE THERE TO
SERVE THE COUNTRY AND THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S IT.
PEOPLE ASKING ME ALL DAY TODAY,
I THINK THE AGENDA OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS .1, TWO,
THREE, FOUR AND A THOUSAND.
THAT SHOULD BE THE FOCUS OF
EVERYBODY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A STORY IN
48 HOURS.
INSTEAD OF BLOWING THIS OUT OF
PROPORTION WITH THE MEDIA ALWAYS
DOES, MAYBE THEY SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON THIS.
LOOK AT THIS PAINTING BY JOHN
McNAUGHTON.
OUT IN UTAH, GREAT GUY, GREAT
PAINTER.
I BOUGHT THAT ORIGINAL PAINTING.
SEE THAT GUY SITTING ON THE
BENCH?
HE REPRESENTS -- THAT'S CALLED
THE FORGOTTEN MAN PAINTING.
THOSE PEOPLE AND FOOD STAMPS.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
JOBS.